bonjour je vais rencontrer une histoire
de sorcière pas la sorcière que vous
connaissez avec son nez crochu
s'emballer et c'est vers eux mais une
sorcière du congo cette sorcière
c'est moi et mon histoire c'est une
histoire de courage des forces et des
fois je suis né en république
démocratique du congo dans une bonne
famille oui quand j'étais petit mon père
étant gens dans une société 2010 diama
on vivait dans une grande maison un
bogie m'a aidé à la province du kassaï
j'allais à l'école et j'étais heureuse
maman elle vient d'une famille pauvre
à cause de cela la famille de mon père
n'aimait pas ma mère puis un jour mon
père a perdu son travail
j'avais 6 ans il a dit à ma mère d'aller
avec moi à kinshasa avec ma soeur et mes
quatre frères
il a dit qu'ils viendront nous rejoindre
pour trouver du travail
en réalité sa femme lui avait demandé de
se débarrasser des nues quand ma mère a
compris il était trop tard se retrouver
tout c'est loin de sa famille elle a dû
vendre tout ce qu'elle avait pour nous
faire manger elle avait changé
elle avait tellement maigri
ma mère a même fait venir notre grand
mère pour nous aider mais nous avions
toujours faim alors ma mère a commencé à
nous envoyer des amis on faisait des
kilomètres à pied pour aller chercher de
la nourriture
c'est comme ça qu'un soir je me suis
retrouvé chez needham qui m'avait donné
à manger pour la femme mais elle était
trop tard pour y tourner elle m'a
proposé de dormir chez elle et de
repartir que le lendemain matin durant
la nuit
j'ai parlé dans mon sommeil ça ne vous
paraît pas très grave n'est ce pas
mais cet ami a dit à ma mère que je
parle aux démons il ya même temps ma
mère et ma grand-mère sont allés
demander des conseils et des prophètes
ce qui représente dieu elle chercher la
cause de tous les malheurs de notre
famille les problèmes et qui m'avait
amené chez un faux prophète et il a été
décidé que c'était moi la cause et que
j'étais une sorcière
les charles a tellement parlé pendant
plus d'une heure pour que j'accepte que
je sois une sorcière
il a crié honte sur moi sans arrêt ils
m'ont fait bord 5 litres d'eau avec des
herbes dégueulasse ils m'ont dit de
venir les viandes des gens que j'aurais
mangé dans le monde des ténèbres
imaginez vous la scène une enfant décède
en face à plusieurs adultes qui crient
sans arrêt on met table même dans le dos
pour faire sortir cette viande à un
moment donné j'avais peur et j'étais
tellement fatigué et j'ai fini par dire
oui je suis une sorcière
je croyais qu'en lisant wiki les mâles
allait s'arrêter mais j'étais devenue
une sorcière
malgré moi une fois commis nommé
sorcière c'était impossible de retourner
en arrière
ma mère a accepté la situation mais ça
ne veut pas dire que ma mère n'aimait
pas et en même temps comme la situation
ne changeait pas dans la maison sans
argent sans culture ma mère a décidé de
décider de partir avec sa soeur à
l'angola pour aller trouver du travail
l'ère blanc la barre j ai ma mère se
retrouver tout seul coincé en angola
sans argent sans nourriture et
finalement n'est pas réveillé contre sa
volonté
elle a été forcée de nous abandonner
elle aussi on a perdu tous les
communications avec elle
et on y reste avec grammaire pendant
deux ans j'ai été traité comme une
sorcière les accusations les cris les
jeunes forcés les piments dans les yeux
elle disait que c'était moi la cause si
ma mère n'a plus le plus elle pensait
qu'elle était morte et que je l'avais sa
criée
elle a dit à tout le monde de ne pas me
dit de ne pas me parler je n'ai pas joué
avec moi dans mon quartier on me
laissait pas m'approcher des autres
enfants j'étais tout s'est jetée pauvres
j'avais faim mais j'étais surtout pauvre
d'amour et finalement ma grand mère elle
m'a chassée de la maison je suis devenu
une gêne est une enfant de la rue dans
la rue on est comme des papillons
l'anglais semaine trouve c'est là on
dort dans la rue on devient des soldats
pour survivre on oublie la lecture et
l'écriture pour apprendre à se battre
dans la rue jeux vendus dès le démarrage
et je fais des ménages
mais cette fois que je jouais les
entrants fall à l'école je me rappelais
des jours où je touristes eux je
pleurais je me demandais si un jour je
pourrai sortir de la rue puis un jour ma
chance a tourné
j'ai pas s'occuper dans un documentaire
kinshasa quitte on m'a payé et j'ai tout
de suite voulu donner cet argent à ma
famille car même dans la rue dès que
j'avais quelque chose je passais aller
voir ma famille pour leur donner ma
grand mère a pris de l'argent
elle m'a encore humide dans la rue plus
tard
j'ai entendu parler d'un film et
canadiennes qui se tourne à kinshasa le
même personne qui s'occupait du casting
alors me connaissez j'ai été invité au
casting
je me suis retrouvé face au regard des
enfants riches qu'ils étaient là en
édition même si j'avais envie de me
sauver à cause de leur regard je suis
resté et j'ai tout donné pour avoir les
rôles pour moi c'était une façon de
changer ma situation j'ai eu le rôle
principal dans le film
c'était bien cool la production ils
m'ont mis dans une grande maison je
pourrai manger tous les jours et à voir
tout ce que je voulais mais malgré tout
ce qui se passait j'étais prise j'en ai
parlé à qui le réalisateur
ma vie était belle mais mes frais et
serge était toujours dans le viseur je
me sentais pas bien quand je mangeais en
sachet qu'ils avaient fait alors
l'équipe et kim ont donné de l'argent à
ma famille et quand l'équipe sont
rentrés chez eux ils m'ont pas laissé
comme ça ils ont trouvé une maison
d'accueil
ils ont fait en sorte que je puisse
retourner à l'école
moi qui en rêvait depuis si longtemps
c'est là où cette histoire de sorcière
devient conte de fées les films a eu
beaucoup de succès et je suis passé de
rues de kinshasa au tapis rouge du
festival
je reste même l'ours d'argent 2012 à
berlin les films a été même nominé aux
oscars et aujourd'hui j'ai 18 ans et que
je reçus dix huit prix dans le monde
les oscars c'est cool mais pour moi les
plus beaux jours de ma vie
ces cellules pour la première fois après
des années dans la rue je suis retourné
à l'école
s'il y a des enfants dans la rue partout
dans le monde
c'est souvent parce que les parents
n'ont pas et les toits d'éducation
comprenez-moi bien les problèmes et
profond la probité ces gamins le macd et
d'éducation chez moi envoyer les enfants
à l'école c'est un luxe mais sans
éducation
on risque de se faire rencontrer
n'importe quoi par les autres qui vous
disent quoi faire et quoi penser ma mère
n'était pas bête
celle qui m'a appris comme abandonné et
comment avoir confiance en soi même mais
s'est fait prendre dans un piège
vous avez tous que l'éducation est
importante mais comment se fait-il que
l'éducation reste usées et que
l'éducation n'est pas arrivée dans le
village de ma mère avant ma naissance
c'est pas cool qu'aujourd'hui avec tout
ce qui existe des technologies et
d'idées que ça ne puisse pas se faire
l'ignorance produit des sorcières
l'ignorance vêtu est alors pourchassé
des sorcières construisons des écoles
moi je m'en suis sorti c'est parce que
j'ai eu beaucoup de chance et de courage
ce n'est pas le cas pour beaucoup
d'enfants qui sont encore d'alary ils
attendent aussi que leurs rêves se
réalisent alors pour cela il faut pas
les oublier
j'ai eu aussi les courage de quitter
kinshasa 17 ans et aujourd'hui j'ai vu
au québec dans une famille d'accueil je
poursuis mes rêves mes études et je
reprends des temps comme avait volé je
vous parle d'espoir et de courage et de
force
je ne veux pas qu'on plaire sur moi je
vais pas complètement je veux pas
arrêter 17 francs
c'est simple aussi longtemps qu'elle
éclaire bas tout est possible merci